and with that the 2022 season comes to
an end good night Jennifer Lopez had
lots to celebrate in 2022 what can I
tell you we're just having a good time
and now she's sharing never-before-seen
moments with husband Ben Affleck on
Instagram the recap video highlights her
favorite moments of the year including
these sweet snaps yup fans are getting
an inside look at the couple's Las Vegas
and George and nuptials I think is very
exciting but that's not all check out
the pair enjoying the Super Bowl and
also having lunch together and of course
packing on the PDA
seems 2022 was quite the year for the
newlyweds and what do you want this year
for Christmas
um
I have everything I want
yeah they even spent their first
Christmas together as a married couple
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in Jen's latest on the JLo newsletter
fans got a glimpse into benifer's
holiday celebration I'm ready I'm
excited about it she explained how
hummingbirds were the theme of the fam's
Christmas party and this designer dress
was perfect for the occasion it was just
perfect last month the source told E.T
quote Jen and Ben had so much fun at
their holiday party and everyone had a
blast
You Can Count On Me
adding quote Ben and Jen know that they
were designed to be together they have
pure awe and love for each other I was
super happy and seems like their
children are loving becoming a blended
family my life is full of abundance joy
and love our source tells us the kids
are quote doing great and get along
effortlessly they all really have
respect for each other Jennifer's
relationship with Ben's kids is natural
and same goes for Ben's bond with
Jennifer's kids
laughs
[Applause]
no doubt the lovebirds had a memorable
year
[Music]